Dans Infinity War, le plus gros mystère du film est imposé par notre fameux docteur strange
Ce dernier, pendant la bataille a vu plus de 14 millions de futurs différents via la pierre du temps...
...Pour vaincre Thanos !
Malheureusement, seul une possibilité sur ses 14 millions montrent les Avengers vainqueur face au Titan.
Et c'est réellement quelque chose qui attise notre curiosité
car Strange affirme tout le long du film qu'il sera prêt à sacrifier n'importe quel avengers dont notamment Tony Stark
Pour sauvegarder la pierre du temps afin que thanos ne mette pas la main dessus
Et contre toute attente au moment du combat contre Thanos sur Titan
Iron man est sur le point de mourir face au titan
Et le Docteur marchande donc avec thanos la vie de tony en échange de lui donner la pierre du temps
Ce qui va à l'encontre de toutes ses promesses.
Thanos gagne donc face aux Avengers et a finalement obtenu toutes les pierres
puis à éradiquer la moitié des êtres vivants dans l'univers...
...via un simple claquement de doigts
Doctor Strange se voit mourir devant Tony Stark lui affirmant que "c'était le seul moyen".
Mais c'est là que le mystère entre en jeu !
Nous savons que Strange détient la solution pour vaincre Thanos
Donc toutes ses actions sont justifiables !
Mais est ce qu'il a sauvé Tony en donnant la pierre du temps à thanos
car ce dernier devait posséder les six pierres pour que nos héros est une chance de gagner ?
Ou bien car tony stark serait la clé pour Avengers 4 ?
La dernière phrase de Docteur Strange confirme qu'un sacrifice aussi énorme était obligatoire !
Joe Russo a d'ailleurs confirmé que thanos devait avoir la totalité des pierres dans le plan de Strange
Mais est ce qu'il n'a pas fait ceci aussi pour sauver Tony
qui pourrait être un élément clé d'Avengers 4
C'est fort possible !
Après tout pourquoi sauver sa vie en échange de la pierre du temps, alors que Strange aurait pu directement donné la pierre
Déjà qu'il n'aimait pas Tony
Si en plus il n'est pas utile à la victoire... Strange l'aurait sûrement laissé !
Tony Stark n'est pas un Avengers comme les autres c'est un génie de la technologie et fait partie des plus puissants Avengers du MCU.
Non pas à cause de sa puissance mais de son intelligence, de sa capacité à s'adapter à n'importe quelle situation
et surtout à prévoir l'avenir. Nous en avons l'exemple avec la conception de "Vision" !
Un personnage parfait pour défendre la population et aider les Avengers
Voire même les remplacer au cas où ils seraient dissociés !
Néanmoins intéressons nous maintenant à Captain Marvel et Ant Man et la Guêpe
Ces deux films se passeront avant Infinity War dans la timeline... mais sortent bien après Infinity War au cinéma
Pourquoi ? Car ces deux films pourraient bien apporter de nouvelles cartes pour la suite d'Avengers 3
si ces derniers sortent après mais se passent avant, c'est qu'ils doivent avoir des éléments de réponses !
...Des solutions à apporter pour la réussite des Avengers.
Pour commencer, Ant man 2 se tournera clairement vers le "Champ Quantique"
Une Zone parallèle où le temps et l'espace sont nuls
Ant Man.. étant le premier protagoniste à être revenu de cette dimension
Nos deux héros : "Scott et la Guêpe" essaieront de manipuler cette zone pour mieux s'en servir dans le futur
Et il est fort probable que ces deux derniers réussissent à faire revenir "Janet Van Dyne"
Femme de Hank Pym et première femme à être le personnage de "la Guêpe" disparu dans le "Champ Quantique" !
Ils la retrouveront d'ailleurs certainement dans le film.
Maintenant si nous nous tournons vers Captain Marvel...
Carol Danvers se verra attribuer son film sur ses origines en mars 2019.
Et le plus intrigant est que ce film se passera dans les années 90 !
D'ailleurs quelque chose d'intrigant aussi reste la scène post-générique du film...
Où Nick Fury, avant de disparaître fait appel au personnage de Captain Marvel
Via un appareil très ancien confirmant que le film sur Carol Danvers se passera dans les années 90.
Mais l'un des gros problèmes est "Comment vont-ils la faire venir dans Infinity War ?"
Qui se passe chronologiquement trente ans après Captain Marvel !
Et bien cela pourrait être grâce au "Champ Quantique" ! Si le temps et l'espace sont absents dans ces dimensions...
Captain Marvel pourrait s'en servir grâce à Ant Man et la Guêpe pour atteindre notre époque.
Ce qui me fait penser ceci d'ailleurs est qu'il est soupçonné que Captain Marvel...
posséderait des pouvoirs en rapport avec le "Champ Quantique"
Et qu'elle sera justement : la héroïne la plus puissante du MCU - D'après ce qui a été déclaré !
De plus, chaque personnage du MCU est présent dans Avengers 4.
Et des photos des personnages ont même fuité
Où nous les voyons habillés comme à une époque antérieure de certains films.
En voyageant à travers les époques pour atterrir à celle d'Infinity War
Nos trois héros pourraient arriver dans ces époques, ne réussissons peut-être pas à
manipuler facilement le "Champ Quantique".
Mais ce qui est sûr est que Carol Danvers est la clé pour vaincre Thanos.
Teasé dans Infinity War, les réalisateurs insistent sur le faite qu'elle est...
Le héros le plus puissant du Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Elle pourrait prendre le rôle d'Adam Warlock dans les comics
En portant le gant de l'infini pour vaincre Thanos... Si elle en est réellement capable ?
C'est une option !
Pour continuer, j'aimerais ajouter que si Captain Marvel, Tony Stark et Ant Man...
...Sont tous les trois réunis, de grandes choses pourraient arriver !
1 - Tony Stark semble être la clé du plan du Docteur Strange si ce dernier le sauva !
2 - Carol Danvers semble être la clé définitive pour vaincre Thanos, notamment grâce à la scène post générique !
3 - Ant Man semble être la clé pour justement amener Captain Marvel à notre époque
Puis effectuer d'autres actions grâce au "Champ Quantique". Ainsi que son pouvoir de devenir énorme !
Imaginez leur trois compétences réunis ? Captain Marvel avec ses pouvoirs et sa puissance
Dans une armure Nanotechnologique créé par Tony Stark et avec le pouvoir de grandir comme Ant Man
Elle serait dévastatrice, surtout si elle est le personnage le plus puissant du MCU. Thanos ne pourrait rien faire !
Néanmoins, ne mettons pas de côté Thor qui vient d'à peine se révéler avec une puissance phénoménale !
A tel point qu'il a failli tuer Thanos.
Ce que nous pensions être le dernier Asgardien aura bien du travail dans Avengers 4
Puisqu'il a été confirmé que Valkyrie sera dans le prochain opus
en compagnie d'autres Asgardiens qui ont réussi à survivre et échapper à Thanos.
Mais n'oublions pas les autres Avengers restants !
Cependant, ne sous-estimez pas Thanos !!
Ce n'est pas parce qu'Avengers 4 sera synonyme de la victoire des Avengers, qu'il n'y aura pas de conséquences.
Déjà... Loki, Heimdall et Vision sont réellement morts... Et nous pouvons entamer notre deuil !
Je vous laisse le bénéfice du doute pour Loki, sachant qu'il fait parti du casting d'Avengers 4
La seule survivante est Gamora qui est enfermée dans la pierre de l'âme.
Cela a été confirmé mais nous en reparlerons dans une autre vidéo si vous me le demandez dans les com's !
Robert Downey Jr & Chris Evans ont terminé leur contrat avec Marvel après Avengers 4
Et je maintiens ce que je disais dans mon "3 Théories sur Avengers Infinity War"
DES HÉROS VONT MOURIR !!
Nous arrivons à la phase 4 et Marvel commence à réellement aller de plus en plus loin dans son univers !
Nous avons quitté la terre depuis un bon moment !
Notamment avec les "Gardiens de la Galaxie"
Nous avons fait face à des ennemis comme des "Célestes", des "Éternels", le Grand Thanos
Et de nouveaux héros plus jeunes et plus forts arrivent !
Regardez le déséquilibrage entre Black Widow et Dr Strange par exemple !
Ou même simplement Captain America mis pas mal en retrait dans Infinity War
Cela fait maintenant une Vingtaine de films que les Avengers d'origines sont présents
Et certains commencent à être mis en retrait ou sont poussés vers la sortie.
Natasha, Banner, Tony, Captain, Oeil de Faucon
Je ne veux pas être médisant mais attendez vous peut-être à quelque chose de macabre !
La relève de ces personnages arrivent et est même déjà présente.
Certaines rumeurs parlent même de personnages qui pourraient prendre le costume d'Iron Man afin de remplacer Tony
Ou bien Captain ?! Bucky le pourrait, il le fait déjà dans les comics.
Seul Thor commence à exploiter toute sa splendeur et aura un rôle à jouer en compagnie...
De nos trois héros : Tony, Captain Marvel et Ant man
Ce que nous savons est qu'Avengers 4 sera très différent d'Infinity War et la seule chose qui a été confirmé...
...Est que Gamora est enfermée dans la pierre de l'âme !
Attendons-nous donc à énormément de surprises de la part de Marvel !
Et faites confiance à Docteur Strange : Tony est un visionnaire !
Captain Marvel et surpuissante et Ant Man maîtrise le "Champ Quantique".
Enfin, j'aimerais d'ailleurs vous partager les vidéos de deux autres vidéastes qui ont aussi partagé une très bonne vision concernant le plan de Docteur Strange.
il s'agit de mon ami
Iro Sef et de Captain Popcorn.
je vous invite à voir leur point de vue ! Les vidéos sont disponibles en description.
N'hésitez pas à me suivre sur Twitter c'est très important !
C'était Argorok et que le LionHeart soit avec Vous !!